[Music]
Hey didn't see you there
how's it goin breath my name is you know
my name [ __ ]
I should stop calling you [ __ ] I'm
sorry and welcome to it's my hair
flawless of course it is not gonna do
anything special today this is just a
little bit of this a little bit of that
between you and me I like doing this
every once in a while it's good to just
talk to you brothers I think that's
important
how are you still alone Karen sorry I'm
kidding I do Karen I honestly I got to
meet with two two brothers from Sweden
really cool guys we got to hang out we
play play video games for a day
they were both Bros who had survived a
really really bad condition they got one
reward for four worth surviving and and
that was their decision was to meet me
and that's so insane like I always hear
like people say that my videos really
helped I doing for the day and they mean
a lot to them but it's it's hard to
believe when you just read the text on
behind a screen so meeting them and
hearing their stories of how they fought
their illness and all that it was I I
can't believe it it really gave me some
perspective on life but also my videos I
really felt like my videos meant
something which I never thought it would
you know IIIi I just started making
videos for fun I never expected anyone
to actually watch so yeah that's that
was amazing so yeah brofist Julianne and
Alban nice meeting you bros oh yeah I
wanted to also let you bros know that
we're launching a website and its called
PewDiePie net right now it's a great way
to just watch videos and there's gonna
be some exclusive videos for PewDiePie
net that is not gonna be on my channel
which I know is a little weird and a
little confusing I hope it won't be I
will try to make
that way I want it to be a place where
you just find extra stuff that I
wouldn't normally be able to upload
because you bruises I don't know if you
realize it but your boroughs are pretty
dang the main thing okay there's a lot
of like games I want to play even though
I know a lot of people will love it I
know a lot of people will hate it so I
don't really end up playing in and I
feel I think that's a shame that one
like stuff like that to live on the
website in the future I want it to be
kind of like a hub for you bros I want
the site for you be for you and as a
place for you all to connect and
butt-sex
no bad sex promised I can't guarantee it
but I will say still I think you boys
should check it out there's a part one
of me playing Mirror's Edge which is
actually one of my favorite games up
right now so you can go ahead check the
link in description and check it out
should be fun probably the best time you
ever had you loser I'm just kidding I'm
so sorry let's be honest you're watching
my videos right now on a Friday
well I'm recording it on a Friday so I
don't even know I don't even know
anymore
that's why we're bros as a final I just
want to say Bruce thank you for the
insane support that's been on the
charity we just hit our goal yesterday
two hundred fifty thousand dollars
that's so awesome
it's I just want to say I can't say
thank you enough for all the generosity
it's been so cool to see you bros being
so positive and excited for this project
this I am that's what makes it like fun
for me to be a youtuber to see to see
that so really it means a lot to me and
it's a really cool thing like we're
doing a good thing we're really changing
people's lives so you bros are awesome
there is however like 27 days left if
you haven't donated yet please go ahead
and check out the link in description we
crushed our goal now let's aim for the
stars baby but yeah that's all for me
for now I'll see you bros in the future
space it's a breakfast for you next
Friday I'll try and I always make this
problem
I'll try big something bit more
interesting than just me talking but
yeah sales and brothers love you